[Musique]
jeff qu'en est il maintenant de ces faux
groupes facebook ou de ces groupes
facebook de faux camionneurs convois
circulent et de plus en plus ouais ben
ça ça fait énormément jaser sur les
réseaux sociaux
etc seul bon paquet de l'europe et de
page facebook associe ou camionneurs qui
s'en va être géré par des comptes
piratés qui sont mal gérées par des gens
qui habitent à l'étranger qui à bien des
gens qui ont qui se tordent ces clubs
pour se mettre à dire je gardais c'est
de l'ingérence étrangère via des
gouvernements étrangers qui a fait de ce
village zizanie au canada ait des
faubourgs facebook un peu comme les
russes ont fait lors de l'élection
présidentielle de 2016 moi quand je
regardais six-fours groupe là j'avais
plutôt l'impression qu'on avait à faire
simplement du marketing d'affiliation
frauduleux il ya toutes sortes de
personnes partout dans le monde
cherchent à tirer profit de tout ce qui
attire des clics sur les réseaux sociaux
et bombay le convoi de camions au canada
c'est le sujet d'un terril le plus
populaire au pays donc c'est pas
surprenant que ces gens-là ce grief à
ces discussions le mieux d'ailleurs un
groupe qu'on a vu celui là qu'on voit ce
que vos plats et géré par deux personnes
qui habitent au bangladesh ça peut avoir
la louche sur la surface mais quand on
regarde comme comme il faut le profil de
ces personnes dans leurs amis on voit
que beaucoup de gens qui semblent faire
du marketing un peu douteux sur les
réseaux sociaux les 2èmes la même tâche
donc une page d'une compagnie de
marketing web qui dit offrent toujours
des services pour peut pas tirer de
conclusions définitives
mais de 10 et les partir en peur mais
dire que c'est de l'ingérence étrangère
elle suit pas vraiment une presse un
responsable de réagir
si on dira tout le monde que l'ingérence
étrangère 100 kg et de preuve
d'ingérence étrangère des fois ça peut
être aussi dangereux que l'ingérence
étrangère dans ce que si tout semble
pointer votre la confusion que ça pourra
être tout simplement
des jeunes qui habitent au prague la
dèche qui essaye de faire de l'argent en
créant des groupes populaires puis
ensuite en essayant de vendre
et produit toutes sortes de manigances
comme on vous ai déjà parlé ou
d'équipement ont fait les dernières
saisons
[Musique]